if you run it on your phone your app
will crash because of a network on main
thread exception
we found this answer by connecting our
device to our computer and then checking
android device monitor for the error
you can see here that this is our app
package name and this is our process id
if you search the logs for that process
id then our error appears
it's triggered ultimately by a network
on main thread exception
if you're curious as to what line of our
code actually caused this you can scroll
down the stack trace to read more
this is all framework code that you can
skip and here's where it actually hits
our app it's within the placeholder
fragment class in the oncreateview
method and it happens in
mainactivity.java file in line 116.
so if we go back to the code
on that line you can see that
urlconnection.connect
actually caused the error and that we
can't do that on the main thread